tu en voilà fonctionnant à 15h30 les
falbalas de jean paul gaultier
un documentaire de tonie marshall voilà
quel boulot quand maman commis alors
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous l'avez
eue là pendant cinq mois a été
absolument étonnant c'est à dire que
je crois qu'il par dylan ss2 on va dire
qu un espèce de petit cimetière de bouts
de tissus de plus une vieille santiag
d'état trucs comme ça
elle arriva derrière et tripote des tas
de morceaux comme ça il tripote
énormément il a absolument besoin de ça
il n'y a pas de dessin il ya maintenant
des trucs collé au mur qui regarde pas
souvent
et puis tripote tripartite riposte de ce
qui a déplu à 20 ans et qui après il
commence à avoir une toile
et puis voilà c'est il ya des choses on
le voit dans le documentaire ya des
moments où ça rate complètement ou pas
etc
et puis tout d'un coup ça vient et là
c'est vraiment intéressant parce que on
voit qu est ce que c'est qu'un moment où
ton parce que jean-paul il ne crée le
vêtement que par la parole il n'arrête
pas de parler
pour l'heure il dit tout en tout temps
alors là le titre on t'a pas si ça fait
ça puis au bout d'un moment ils arrêtent
de dire le tissu il commence à dire
alors là je vais avoir ça un peu plus
serré dit dont l'âge de cloques et puis
alors là je god
donc je vais remonter alors il faut il
faut je ne suis pas doubler et il se met
absolument à la place du vêtement et à
partir de là le discours structure alors
qu'avant je viens le vêtement il devient
vêtements et qui se répondent et ça est
un peu après il perfectionne les cinglés
quoi moyens cintrée alors il ya un autre
événement concernant jean paul gaultier
c'est l'exposition pain couture by jean
paul gaultier la fondation cartier pour
l'art contemporain
aulas il a transformé mille mètres
carrés en boulangerie il nous fait deja
bompas vous allez regarder votre caméra
on va recommencer l'expérience à 3 0 et
auxerre avec vincent la halle et vincent
humain à humain attention un deux trois
magnéto serge